معنى الان من القاهره السيده ليلى سويف
والده علاء عبد الفتاح اهلا بك سيد ليلى
على فرانس 24
نتحدث عن وضع ابنك اضراب لمده سبعه اشهر
عن الطعام الان علاء عبد الفتاح توقف عن
او انقطع عن شرب الماء بدايه الموضوع
الصحيح حاليا
بلغني في خطاب ان هو من النهارده هيبقى
منقطع عن شرب المياه فانا بكره رايحه همم
وجه النصر
بحيث انه يقدر يكتب لي خطاب واعرف بالضبط
همم
بعد كده هيبقى يعني همم
يعني لابد من المتابعه يوميه انا طبعا مش
عارفه الحقيقه هل فعلا الشيطان مصريه
هتدينا اخبار يوميه ولا يعني هتعمل ايه
لانه هم للاسف
ههه
بتنكر انه علاء همم نضرب عن الطعام
فيعني مش عارفه رد فعلهم في اللحظات دي
بقى هيبقى عامل ازاي واحنا بقينا على
المحطه يعني المساله همم
ايام همم لو لو ما كانش تصرف ثانيه همم
في الوقت الحالي اما ربما هناك صديقات على
هذه المساله بتاعتها
احنا استنفذنا اخر زياره خلاص مع يعني
الموعد الزياره القادمه يوم 17 طبعا ده
يعني همم
لو علاء منقطع عن شرب المياه احنا مش
هنوصل يوم 17
همم عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ايضا عبر
الكثير من القنوات هل بنظركم وهذا
الانقطاع عن شرب المياه الذي اعلن عنه
شقيقه علاء ايه يتزاء من هو عقد هذه هذا
المؤتمر المؤتمر المناخ هل تتوقعون ربما
افراجا على علاء بالتزامل مع عقده هذا
المؤتمر
الحقيقه انا مش عارفه يعني مش عارفه اتوقع
يعني
شخصيا مش متوقع
عليه شخصيه متوقع انه الشرطه المصريه
راهبه انه هو يموت في السجن وهو قرر ان هو
يتحكم في التوقيت بحيث في سبب له اكبر حرق
ممكن
هناك رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الذي قال
لشقيقه علاء انه سينتهي الفرصه للحديث عن
وضع على وبالتالي الحديث عن ايه افراج
ممكن عن هل هناك ضمانات من بريطانيا التي
تحمل او التي تحمل على جنسيتها
يعني هو ال ال ال ال
السلطات البريطانيه دائما متاكد لنا
الموضوع عليها اولويه عليه عندها بس
ظننتظم بريطانيه بتتكلم مع السلطات
المصريه في موضوع علاء بقى لها شهور
ومافيش والملح والموضوع ما بيتحركش
هل دلوقتي
الموضوع هيتحرك ولا لا يعني انا انا مش
عارف انا انا فعلا مش عارفه اتمنى اتمنى
ان طبعا يعني همم
قلقه جدا عليه همم
وكمان متصوره انه لو همم حصل له حاجه
اثناء ده مش مصلحه اي احد يعني يعني لا في
مصلحه السلطات المصريه وانا في مصلحه
السلطنيه ولا في مصلحه
اتمنى انه يبقى في تحرك سريعه عشان
الموضوع
نتمنى ذلك سيده ليلى سويف ااا شكرا جزيلا
لك على وجودك معنا في هذه النشره وردت
علاء عبد الفتاح حدثنا من القاهره شكرا
جزيلا لك